last year slash this year do you have a
plan for supplementation what I have
done over the last say nine months which
has and this is going to sound like a
Shameless plug cuz I'm involved with
these guys but probably what I would do
this ski season is I would have a
NeverEnding supply of Maui Nei venison
sticks like the unsweetened like no
additional sugar and that has proven for
me to be just about the easiest way to
get nutrient dense 30 grams of protein
in the morning I can just throw those in
my ski jacket too so that will probably
take the place of eggs yeah also just
for convenience in terms of
supplementation I would say last year
kept it pretty simple I would say I was
taking magnesium some
electrolytes generally magnesium in the
morning and then I went back and forth
on Creatine I know that there are so
many different benefits to creatine I
was cognizant of not wanting to carry
too much weight like additional water
weight if I was going to retain a lot
more water oh yep so I use that
intermittently I would often use that
around cross training so if I was like
kind of going to the gym yeah athletic
greence again it's sound like a plug but
I've been using that stuff since 200
whatever n or 10 and supplementation we
could say you know I could be brief here
if you'd like M but absolutely making
sure magnesium is there magnesium is
released in sweat at very low quantities
but it's still enough When you sweat the
amount that you're
potentially and also with with skiing
like I'm going to sweat my ass off yeah
I'll be working so we want to make sure
that that stuff is high creatine is
great if you're going to use it I
wouldn't use it the way you did okay I
would use it or don't okay got so having
it like on certain days or not is
probably not make it daily or not yeah
because it takes a chronic effect yeah
for it to really start to matter unless
you're going really high dosage MH so I
wouldn't be super concerned about the
water retention aspect of it because
might even be a plus yeah I was going to
say we're having a problem with that
anyways right any recommendation if you
try and doesn't work you don't like it
and what are we talking about like 5 g a
day or would it be that's the number
that's the standard that's what everyone
throws out but I would say the same
thing of like like the protein yeah why
cand leaf for guys our size it's fine
I'm probably going higher I'm also never
measuring greine to be totally honest
like I'm just taking big Scoops and
throwing it in there yeah like seeing
what happens there's actually really
interesting data on the more recent
stuff the more interesting stuff on
Creatine is around bone health brain
health and overall even like mood brain
health is no joke yeah yeah but that's
been 10 to 20 gram a day I have
experimented with that chronically and
just looking at verbal I mean it's
recall yeah and also just like verbal
Acuity and stuff in podcasts I mean I've
looked at at this somewhat it's nend of
one it's just self-reporting but for me
it's pretty noticeable you don't have to
do N1 there's data yeah there's tons of
it out there that's nothing's perfect
but yeah there's actually another review
article just this week came out also on
Creatine and brain health mhm so whether
you're looking at dementia Alzheimer's
AR and stuff like that it's there's no
perfect answer there but you can see the
data anything else you would add to the
list the rest of it would be dependent
upon your labs in your physiology what
we knew there you could throw in you're
never going to be hurt for the most part
adding vitamin D it's a very yeah common
one you're going to be on the sun all
day so well half of my face will be out
in the sun all
day there'll be significant Sun blockage
I hope so yeah uh yeah I I did
supplement with d last year yeah and
fish oil I also supplement with fish oil
yeah could be Placebo who knows there's
probably literature out there on this
but I found it to seemingly help with
sleep quite a bit those would be the
standard kind of without knowing
anything about you you throw in that
cocktail you're talking about things
that are fairly cheap yeah again
relatively yeah they have very little
cross reaction mhm unlike minerals yeah
unlike even high dos of vitamins you're
playing a game there that you may want
to be a bit careful of M but things like
vitamin D and things like Omega meaning
just unintended side unintended yeah
side effects yeah yeah you don't want
know what problem you're solving really
and so you're just sort of throwing
stuff in there that can technically
happen with anything even vitamin D and
heavy metals MH can be concerned there
but it's a very rare thing so most of
the time like you're fine I feel
comfortable saying like most people can
jump on that train for all those and be
totally
fine